[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to do this episode we're covering
DC's latest comic book extravaganza
Shazam and breaking down everything that
you need to know about the movies ending
and all the cool early stir eggs that
are in the film make sure you stick
around until the end for my review of
Shazam where I'll be letting you know
whether to go out and see in theaters or
just to wait for the blu-ray from here
on out its full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want to know anything about the
film then I highly recommend that you
turn off now for everyone else thanks
for clicking the video sit back relax
and let's get into my ending explain
breakdown of Shazam Shazam opens with a
young dr. sivana traveling home with his
brother and father
Suvarna is really looked down upon by
the two and we get the feeling that his
brother is the favorite while see sort
of the outcast things start looking up
though when he's transported to the rock
of eternity during a ride and he meets a
wizard known as Shazam Shazam is in
search for someone pure of heart to
tackle the manifestations of the seven
deadly sins but when they eventually
break out of their holdings in his
dimension there's a little cameo from
mr. mind which I'll get into more later
and it seems like Suvarna is going to be
the next champion until the whisperings
of the sins tempt him to take their
power due to this Suvarna is cast out
and back on the road he accidentally
causes his father to crash the car
they're riding in paralyzing him in the
process eagle-eyed DC fans will
recognize sivanna's father as actor John
Glover who also played Lionel Luthor in
TV Smallville man that guy is amazing at
raising super villains
anyway flash-forward to current day and
we joined Billy Batson fourteen-year-old
boy who's in search of his mother Batson
luster during a visit to the carnival
and has been moving from foster home to
foster home trying to track it down to
no avail
there's a nice little reference to
Batman Begins and The Dark Knight Rises
with the policeman putting a blanket
around the young Batson in order to
comfort him after just losing his
parents it's just a shame that
Commissioner Gordon wasn't on the case
because maybe he could have found
mother as the excuse they gave that he
couldn't crack her down is that she just
changed her maiden name which anyway
Batson gets moved to a new foster home
and quickly forms a friendship with the
other children there including superhero
obsessed Freddie Freeman Freddie owns a
replica batarangs has multiple aquaman
t-shirts and even managed to obtain a
deflected bullet that was shot off
Superman meanwhile a doctor sivana has
spent decades looking for a way back to
the rock of eternity so that he can
prove he's worthy after interviewing
multiple people with shared experiences
sivanna figures out the symbols to
create a doorway back to the realm
taking the original power that the sins
tempted him with whilst they possess and
inhabit his body left with no real
choice the wizard Shazam bestows the
power of Shazam upon Billy who with the
help of Freddy slowly starts to figure
out his powers there's some absolutely
hilarious scenes in here when Billy
stopped to store robbery and he quickly
becomes a local celebrity racking up
thousands of views on YouTube a bit like
another hero that I know don't forget to
like subscribe comment it anyway the
fame sort of goes to Billy's head and he
becomes more of an acting hero
dodging his responsibilities as much as
possible and we all know with great
power comes great nevermind that's wrong
hero because of this he and Freddy fall
out and Freddy sort of becomes a
laughingstock at school after bragging
that Shazam would have lunch with him as
he's his best friend but guess what he
never shows
sivanna aware that if Billy gains his
full potential he'll be able to defeat
him tracks him down and tries to take
his power there's an awesome floor
keyboard reference too big which is of
course a big influence on this film but
Billy takes the coward's way out during
the fight and bleeds from it Suvarna
spots freddy hugh recognizes from a new
shot and kidnaps him which leads him to
the foster home where he holds the
family hostage at this point with the
help of his foster brother and some
Hackerman skills billy tracks down his
mother but upon showing up at her door
he realizes that she purposely left him
at the carnival when she realized that
she wouldn't be able to take care of him
properly due to her only being 17 and
his father being in jail shoutouts barry
allen anyway Billy realizes he has a new
family and returns at the home to take
Sivan
who takes him to the rock of eternity to
transfer his powers the foster family
follow him and after Freddy throws a
Batarang off his head they realized that
he goes back to being mortal if the sins
were out of him
Husum Monsters Inc inspired doorways and
a cameo from crocodile man and
eventually the group returned to the
carnival that belly was left at which is
where Suvarna shows up to take his power
once more
Shazam realizing that his power comes
from the heart and that his family or
that to him now is able to transfer his
power into all of his foster family and
nurse create the Shazam kids anyone
who's read flashpoint knows how badass
these guys are and I love that Adam
Brody finally got to be in a DC film but
those who don't know Brody was actually
cast as the flash in George Miller's
Justice League film however the movie
was cancelled just days before it was
due to shoot so it finally seems like
justice is served
sorry that joke was terrible anyway they
defeat the sins and Billy is able to
deep power Savannah and lock him up
their fighters Man of Steel written all
over it with some hilarious villain
monologuing that falls on deaf ears the
family grow closer and Freddy sits down
for lunch which is when Shazam joins him
confirming that they do indeed know each
other just to add some extra oomph to
the end of the film
Shazam says he brought a friend which is
when Superman walks in and sits down
beside them now this last shot can be
taken two ways we never actually see
Henry Cavill in the suit and Superman's
appearance is completely neck down I did
actually have a member of staff from
Warner Brothers contact me a couple of
months back after they got to see an
assembly curve the film and they said
that the Superman shot was originally
supposed to be an insert whilst they
work things out behind the scenes with
Henry Cavill unfortunately it doesn't
look like they were able to come to an
agreement but I actually think the shot
still works and that Warner Brothers
probably managed to save the shed load
of money cut the credits and we get an
awesome animation that shows Shazam
interacting with the rest of the Justice
League and kind of owning them left
right and center now the first post
credit scene picks up with dr. sivana in
his cell trying to recreate the symbols
to open the door back to the rock of the
I'll know where a raspy robotic voice
tells him that it's useless and there
are other ways to obtain magic which is
when we see mr. mind who escape the rock
of eternity earlier has returned mind is
part of the monster Society of evil and
this is a sort of lower tier Legion of
Doom
made up of members like dummy mr. hoo
and crocodile man black adam has to been
a member from time to time and this sets
of the casting of the rock is the
character for the inevitable sequel
because let's face it this movie's going
to kill it
sivanna eventually joins them and this
meeting makes a lot of sense for the
future personally though I've always
viewed these as kind of joke characters
and they're not really headline acts for
DC graphic novels so it seems strange
that Warner Brothers have decided that
they should be the next foe but
obviously they bring a wealth of
dynamics to the proceedings so it seems
like creators are aiming to continue the
fun and friendly aesthetic of this movie
the last post-credit scene is just a gag
that was shown in trailers and doesn't
really tease anything for the future the
scene shows Shazam attempting to speak
to his fish as Freddie Freeman watches
this is of course a little nudge and
acknowledgement of Aquaman but it's
bound to disappoint those who are
expecting a big cameo from one of DCs
a-listers and now onto my review
Shazam was a hell of a lot of fun DC
have been criticized recently of copying
Marvel too much but here the family
friendly vibe works a treat the movie is
hilarious from start to finish and
there's a self-awareness to it that
makes it really easy to get into casting
is pitch perfect here with Jack Dillon
who plays Freddy Freeman
really being the runaway star for me he
adds a wealth of humor to the
performance but also hot when necessary
Zachary Levi Zachary Levi Zachary Levi
is about to become a household name and
I promise in a couple of months I'll be
able to pronounce his name properly
because it feels like he embodies a kid
that's been bestowed with these powers
what do you think the third act goes on
a bit too long with a ferris wheel scene
that was completely unnecessary
ultimately this is another step forward
for DC who've been nailing it recently
this is the best Captain Marvel movie of
the year
and you should definitely go and check
this out in theatres
as it's gonna be a people obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the film
and where you rank it amongst the rest
of the DC Universe comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then make sure you check out my full
breakdown of last week's big movie us
which would be linked at the end I also
do a comic book movie podcast called
watching The Watchmen the hardcore DC
fans who want a bit more long-form
analysis of their favorite books which
are leave a link to after this video
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]